All right. Uh, welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end. Uh, second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Uh,
therefore, no classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch out and finally
the talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's
about it. Now let me briefly introduce
our speaker today. Um it is an honor to
host Dr. uh Bren Brenster who did his
PhD
studying bosbone decays at the CMS
experiment at the large ardon collider
at CERN. In 2018 uh he joined the SAP um
O fight writers group in Litz Australia.
uh in 2021 he became Ellis postto at Max
Wellings lab at the University of
Amsterdam before joining uh the newly uh
founded Microsoft lab in Amsterdam.
During his time at Microsoft
research was working on scaling up of
AIdriven physics uh surrogates most
notably for weather and climate
simulations. In October 2023, Johannes
um moved back to Austria and uh started
a new group AI for datadriven
simulations at the Institute of Machine
Learning at the Johannes uh Kepler
University English. Additionally, in
2024, Jonas was uh chief researcher at
NXAI uh GmbH. Um the recently uh the
Jonas um co-founded MEAI where he is
currently is the chief scientist. Uh
today Jonas will uh talk about the next
wave of scientific breakthroughs
uh is in the latent space. I'm sure we
are going to hear a wonderful talk. Now
let me ask a informal somewhat informal
question to him just to get to know him
um a bit better and make this uh
presentations seminar a bit informal. Uh
so here is my questions for you. I I
know that you love mountains and you are
in Austria right now and near the Alps
mountain. How what what is the maximum
height you you you got into? Um Oh, I
that's a good question. I I have to have
have to say there's a lame answer to
that. I only was at the highest peak of
Austria, which is 3,800, which is not
quite impressive um compared to other
peaks in other parts of the area, but
it's at least the highest in in our
country. Oh yeah. So, okay. So, you
conquer the highest in Austria. There's
not nothing higher to conquer. No.
Okay. So the next step would be um the
higher points in other country I think.
Yes, exactly. You would need to go to
Switzerland or Italy. I see. All right.
The floor is yours. Yeah. Thank you very
much for the introduction. Thank you
very much for having me. Um I'm quite
excited to be here.
I talk about latent space. I I talk
about science doing being done in the
latent space. Um I will have this a bit
interwined with my personal view on
spatial temporal challenges which we
face in
modeling. This very much comes from um
from the fact that that we we all hear
so much about LLMs and about scaling up
and about solving large and larger
problems.
Maybe neglecting a bit the fact that
tokenization or how we present problems
even to an I system is something which
is very different in physics and in
engineering and in science in general
compared to language. And even if we
think of language, just if we think of
how long it took the holy eye field to
come up with the right tokenizers, it
might be um not so straightforward to
come up with the right way we present um
we present science to to to to large
scale models and even um if you know how
to present science, how we we even model
like um spatial temporal um um
relationships. I started to to to really
think um more about um many different
engineering problems in the last two
years coming from a I have to quote
Tanya uh sorry for that if if you listen
in. Um this is a quote I I extremely
like and I heard um um two months ago.
Um and and this is I think what what
people in machine learning should should
try especially in science to attach
yourself to solving a problem to to
coming up with the best methods or the
best ways to solving a problem and not
attaching yourself to a method basically
being I've invented X Y Z so so this is
the best method but rather using using
or rather really trying to solve
problems that is uh what I want to talk
about in combination with my personal
view on on on latent case um I have to
say I don't want to make any um
advertisement about my company uh
because this is a science talk but I
have to ground a bit the or motivate a
bit the the the the work I'm talking
about the problems I'm talking about
with the problems of of engineering
which we're tackling in the company so I
will give you a very quick elevator
pitch which I would give to an investor
so if you have if you're an investor I
have to tell you um that the field of
engineering ing as we currently know
compared to language vision is very very
unexplored. Um but if you think of the
the the true potential which is all
these engineering problems there's many
many verticals you can untap. If you
think of manufacturing, logistics,
engineering and my personal bet is that
the
biggest market to unlock with AI is is
datadriven simulation and digital twins.
So this is what you would say to an
investor. But if you were to speak to a
for to a colleague who is doing as AI as
well and if you want to convince him to
join your company, you would say the
following. You would say something like
that.
Um it's basically quite well understood
how we model text and how we model
images. But how would you model let's
say a Formula 1 car? How would you solve
or how would you model that the flow
field around the Formula 1 car? Um given
that if we do a proper CFD simulation
which is done in a threedimensional
space around the formal one cara you
would then need a billion mesh cells
what's the best way of of of
constructing surrogates neural network
help to to model that similarly I asked
myself like two years ago what's the
best way to model multifysics phenomena
multifysics phenomena as an example here
just ignore the lower line um you have
these particles half a million of
particles they are bouncing
around driven by a air which is which is
coming from below um and which which
basically is doing an an an interaction
but in order to model this interaction
it's very very complicated dynamics
which is very hard to uh to understand.
So what's the best way to model that?
And this is in my opinion still a very
very open question because the the field
we are we are um operating in is in the
in the whole um is is basically in the
range of where fluid dynamic is
happening where CFD is happening where
uh mechanical simulations are happening
and they're very similar relevant
simulations are are thermo electric
thermodynamic simulations and so on and
so forth. So this is this is the field
we're playing. This is the field we're
trying to um to to to come up with new
um
breakthroughs and and this comes up with
my personal view of of challenges or of
how we model space and time because all
the simulation have some something like
a spatial and temporal component. And
when we talk about space and time, we
have to remind ourselves of of of how we
actually model space and time in
numeric. and and numeric I I want to
stress at the beginning is a field which
works since two thou 200 years. This is
a field which is super well developed
where we know how how we get guarantees
where we know what what type of
algorithm works for for what type of
problem and how we designing this type
of problems. Um there is one very
rudimentary rule of how numeric works
for temporal problem and this is very
very rude approximation.
um but I think it's it's it's still
valid for 99% of the problems. So what
you would do is you look at your
problems, you look at your equation and
you you look at the problem as a as two
type of of subpros. The one is the the
right hand side and these are all the
physic um operators like convection,
diffusion, advection um whatever which
you can write as spatial derivatives and
and combination of uh of different uh
fields you have in your system.
And that's actually the tricky part to
estimate these this this all these
derivatives all these operators by some
some tricks like finite difference
finite volume um um and and and and and
and different
schemes. And then and the second
challenge or the second sub challenge is
to use this estimator which you do on
the right to do an update on on the
whole system on the left which is
usually then a ordinary differential
equation which just means a temporal
update because you have eliminated all
these other uh spatial terms by by using
some approximation to them. easily. You
can see that if you look at the finite
difference scheme which has different um
different ways of approximating
derivatives for um by by using
neighboring pixels and combining them in
a way that you get approximation with
some error guarantees depending on on
how close you use and how many
neighboring points you take.
So this is a way how machine learning
started by and I look at the the
progress of machine learning in model
spatial temporal system by exactly at
looking this equation. So the first
works which came out and which were
really eyeopening for me were to to to
come up with estimates for the right
hand side. So for example um the Google
paper from 2019 um as as I put here on
the right they come up with estimates
for these spatial derivatives. combine
these estimates given by the neural
network and make an update in time.
Similarly, the the group of Peter
Battalia at Google deep mind started to
um to use um estimates for the for the
ex acceleration of of each particle in
many different um different simulations
to give an update or or to feed this
acceleration to a numerical um solver
which which does an oiler update and and
and updates the next position of each
particle. So what these systems are
doing they they they they solve or they
give good approximation for the right
hand side even approximation which might
be better or more accurate uh or but at
least faster than the predictions you
would get from numeric. I was very
intrigued by that and started uh or we
started to work on that roughly I think
six years ago using this this type of
models. Um the problem is if this is a
failure case, you would normally not
show failure cases in a in a
presentation, but this is a very typical
failure case. You see the ground truth
on the right and the prediction on the
left and it's it's the similar network.
You predict acceleration of these
particles. You propagate them forward in
time. Problem is that this is a very
complex geometry. It does not look
complex, but the the surface is a
triangularized surface and these
particles interact with the surface. So
somehow I have to to to model this the
surface interaction also with the node
in this graph network and it's just very
hard to get this this this interactions
right and if you make a tiny error in
these interactions if one of these
accelerations is predicted wrongly and
then you do the temporal update and make
the next prediction and so on and so
forth errors accumulating which leads to
catastrophic behavior quite quickly. So
obviously it took us some time to get it
to work. At the end this it worked and
and and the network was modeling this
this quite accurately but the the
problem was really it was extremely hard
to get it to work. It was really
challenging and we somehow always had
the feeling squeezing the model into
this numerical framework that it
works. I would say um big big shout out
to Andreas Meer who did that back in the
days.
Um it was a bit unsatisfying to to not
the project itself but to see that the
limitations of machine learning in this
in these type of errors um compared to
to how machine learning was was
excelling in in other areas. And that
got me think and and I I I didn't have
an answer back in the days.
What then happened in the community is
that people started to jump over um this
the this this differentiation between
spatial updates and temporal updates.
What people did next is they predicted
the the next state of the system
basically in one go. So they up they put
in the state of the system at time point
t they predicted how the system is
evolving in t. There is um many many
works. I think the one of the most
impressive areas is weather modeling
which uh uh which which started I don't
know roughly three four years ago and
which leads to this impressive weather
modeling like graphcast aurora and so on
and so forth which are now on the
market. This is a triumph on on on
modeling very difficult systems on very
high resolution by using the network as
simulator for for for the system
predicting the step state of the system
forward in time. Again we have basically
get rid of this this temporal problem.
what is a bit um what what we exchange
the complexity of the geometry to higher
resolutions more complex simulations and
we exchange graph networks to something
like transformers in the
um and
now I want to go back to to to typically
engineering use cases um which you which
you have when you um when you look at at
problems um um as as I showed in the
introduction you have a very different
um different problem setup. So you have
this this ratio of of of cells um to
information which is very different than
in videos and also in weather where the
the the information is very fine grained
in weather. The information is not that
fine grained in in many of these
information in in in these scenarios. So
so the ratio is just different. It's
very geometrydriven. So geometry is a
central part of of these problems. Not
only that there you have flows around
geometry and and and and mixing stuff
but you also that geometry itself can
can form. So if you have say like
injection molding or if you um if you
look at some material which is which is
bending geometry itself is forming
depending on stresses it is exposed to.
Next you have a lot of interactions of
particles, fluids, geometries and what
that means that that you really have to
rethink the way of of how encoding
works.
Um before we go to the encoding, I would
say the name of the game is is is to use
the concept of neural operators, to use
the concept of thinking of functions, of
thinking of underlying um functions from
which you sample and to think of the
input as a function from which you
sample. It should not matter how you
sample from the input. It should not
matter how many points you sample. You
should come up with the similar
representation, if not the same
representation of the input. that is
enormously important because then you
can use this representation in more
compressed latent space as we will see
later. Um the way we are thinking about
it and there's there's I think many
different works in that area which are
doing um similar steps is by coming up
with an efficient latent space modeling
which consists of a compression and a
decompression algorithm and this
decompression is very general. Um it
means that that it it takes into account
that different points and and and it has
an property which means discretization
convergence. Meaning that if you have a
different number of points, you would
come up with the same um representation
and if you query the model at different
output points, you you basically come up
with sampling from the same
function. Um intuitively just explaining
the concepts. Obviously the the devil is
in detail and each of the steps is is is
tricky and it needs to be seen what's
the best way of doing it. Um I think one
of the or I walk you through the steps
now think just of a bunch of particles
you want to encode. Um one thing which
many of these simulations have in common
as I said the ratio of information
content is very different than videos
and images. That means to some some rate
you can do a heavily sampling heavily
subsampling um which which not only
leads to data augmentation but which
also reduces the problems drastically.
We're talking about 99% of subsampling
in some
cases. Um so you can do this this heavy
subsampling which is um which is in in
one way or the other um very different
to the systems we know and and then
basically you need to have two steps. uh
the first is a local aggregation that is
very important because even if you
subsample systems might be extremely
large. So the um aggregating of the
information needs to be local that you
can distribute um um the the the problem
over over GPUs and then you can reduce
each GPU or each GPU is only locally
looking at at neighboring information
and when you have this so-called um as
we call it super nodes the so-called
local champions which have aggregated
information you basically already in the
setup that you have something like a
token then you add information on top of
it and then you get your your latent
space which you can rather either
compress further or you add some
additional information on it. Um you can
mix this latent space with other um
encodings and and whatever whatever
you're you're you're getting. So the the
gist here is that we we have a in
engineering in many engineering use
cases in also in many physics use cases
they are very much intertwined. you have
a a subsampling strategy which which
needs to be very well understood. That
is obviously the the big challenge. I'm
not saying that that this is solved. You
have a local aggregation step and then
you have a global aggregation step. Then
you get a very compressed
representation. And now if I show you a
that the similar input but with double
as many points, you should get the same
representation or a representation which
is very close to this representation.
um the the decoding happens in a in a
similar way just the other way around.
I'm not I'm not uh show focusing too
much on that because um that that um
that goes um that puts away too much of
our time. More important than or more
interesting than this this local the
spatial aggregation is the concept of
time. Um we are currently in a in a
discussion about what's really the best
way for a lamp. Is it really predicting
the next token or is it um is it is it
is more intuitive to
predict a like a
uh a whole text and iteratively refine
it. Similarly in in physics predicting
the next state of the of the system
comes with lots of limitations like
systems are not consistent system starts
to hallucinate and so on and so forth.
Um what what is however really the
important to note is that machine
learning is very good at understanding
structure. It's very good at
understanding general structure over
over different um um time steps. But
what machine learning is not good is is
extracting cor very very precise update
rules.
I want to now make a big bit of a sw uh
switch and talk about one specific
project which is only to motivate uh my
thinking of time because doing this
project somehow really changed the way I
I um I think of time and I think of how
we should model
time. It is a a project which uh it's
not uh publicly available yet. you will
see uh very soon and and what we're
trying to do is compress some um data
from from black hole mergers. So from
from these massive stars which merge
which are modeled by general relativity
simulation. General relativity
simulation means that you're modeling a
five dimen four dimensional spacetime
given by Einstein's field equation which
look very neat but if you write it down
these are uh 10 um coupled tensor
equations which are very very nasty and
are very very hard to compute and if you
if you were to to run these numeric if
you look at the numeric from this one
black hole merger simulation you come up
with data which is which is around a
terabyte of of of data which is super
hard to store which is super hard to to
handle and even if you want to extract
physics from this data like jodessics
it's very hard because you you need the
underlying mesh which is changing um
adaptively if you go to to to to things
like um singularity where you need much
much much much finer mesh points in
order to get the derivatives roughly
right. Um so this is a very challenging
way in just not only storing the data
but also how to obtain physics. We had
the idea to use um neural fields as
scene representation which allow us to
compress this simulation very heavily
and then um do with automatic
differentiation allows us to to
reconstruct physics. Um I'm not
spoilering this more. I just wanted to
show you that I'm really excited about
this project. You can can look it up
yourself as soon as it out and you can
judge yourself.
The important point is I wanted to show
you my excitement because if you're
excited about something, you think about
it a lot. And I'm thinking about it a
lot. Which also made me rethink the way
we look at time because at some point in
the in the the last couple of months,
years, half a year, I started to not
think about space and time as two
different things. I started to think
about one thing. Um, and that is very
interesting. I I'm I'm I'm actually at
the moment in New York. I flew in here
uh I think on Monday this week. Usually
when you when I fly somewhere and and
you you ask me where are you going to
fly? I have this mental picture of going
from from Europe um to the US and I have
this this error which which basically
follows the geodessics. This is the the
mental picture I have in my head. So
during or when I explain what I'm doing
when when explain where I'm flying I I I
literally see this this little arrow
representing the uh the airplane going
from Europe to the US um and and going
like a movie following a path and I
realized this week when when I was asked
at the airport where you going that
there was no error moving it was like
this geodessics was there so so
basically the line was there as if as if
it it there is no temporal component of
it. So I basically my my head um um um
erased this temporal unfolding and and
made a straight line of it or a
geodessic out of it which is kind of
interesting because this is coming from
this way of thinking about relativity
and this um is a very important concept
in in in in neural networks now as well.
So let's first um go to the latent space
do all these things which I explained
before but now use really the power of
latent space. There is one fundamental
or one gamechanging work for me in the
last five years. I mean there's many
many gamechanging works but one which
was is really gamechanging for me is
stable diffusion. Um not because you can
get such nice pictures of of dogs and
and and whatnot. um not because um it it
it it basically um is is is is something
which starts in Europe but because of
the concept to to train two separate
models an encoder and a decoder which
give you a very compressed
representation on which you can run your
diffusion process that you can really
decouple the training the the model from
how we encode scenes. And if you think
of physics or engineering, you can
really decouple the way um we we we
model our our system or we emulate our
system with the way how we represent our
system. And that is very very very
appealing. The next thing which made me
realize is that obviously the the uh the
the diffusion stable diffusion gang was
was making progress and stable diffusion
3 is about modeling videos and the the
work is called align your your latent.
It's following the similar principles.
I'm not going into detail, but what it
has is it has this additional temporal
axis. So, it's modeling time and it's
basically aligning the latence over
time. It's treating the whole thing,
sorry for the misuse of the word, as a
tensor and it aligns over the uh over
the the temporal dimension. And that is
really interesting for me because
suddenly we we think of this latent
space as a compact tensor over which you
try to make things consistent which is
very much from the fuel I had from from
from this this general relativity
space-time thinking. And this this is a
this is an interesting concept because
uh we have this this this
four-dimensional um spacetime which we
know from general relativity and and we
see that this that video generation
actually allows us to model time as
another dimension over which you align.
So the question is more and more is
autogressive modeling really the right
choice or should we think of something
like a temporal alignment? Um,
interestingly I I really start to
rethink um if we model that language
even right because always predicting
next word and the next word and next
word is how a human would do it if you
speak because you you basically um you
speak if you write you write the next
word but in the end you have already a
concept in in your mind. So wouldn't it
better to to predict the whole um text
at once and then iteratively refine the
text. So basically allowing the the
output to to look back and forth in the
future and to align all these tokens. Um
there is very nice works in that area.
Um which are I call it roaring diffusion
models mostly are inspired by by this
this paper of David Ru and colleagues
but there is similar concepts now um
happening in in late space and for LLMs
and this what this the this RO diffusion
models are doing um they have a
diffusion process at each time step um
independently. So basically each time
step diffuses depending on on how far um
it is away from from the current time
step. So the farther you're away the
higher the in the in this diffusion
window in this time window the farther
you're away the higher is your noise
level and the more you come to to the
actual time that the more the noise is
decreased. Interestingly you you
basically cross the tent you align
between these diffusion steps. That
means um you always you you diffuse
depending of what the future and your
past is telling you. a very interesting
concept, very not how how we would do it
numerically, but very much how it makes
sense from a machine learning
perspective. Um, and I and I like this
concept and this is this is very much um
in this in this this way of rethinking
time. There is also this this this um
um interpretation of diffusion models.
there's this extremely nice block of
sand tie um that there's different
interpretations of diffusion models and
one interpretation is to see them as a
uh as a as a autogressive model in the
frequency space. So iteratively you you
get better modeling of frequencies. You
get better understanding of frequencies.
The the the lower the amount of noises
which you're uh reducing the the the
more you are in the higher up you are in
the frequency spectrum because there is
this um this this relation between um
low frequency which which have high
magnitude and high frequency which have
low magnitude. So meaning having a noise
with low magnitude meaning you're
refining high
frequencies. We did a similar work on on
PTE. So we recon we we reuse the the uh
diffusion concept to iteratively refine
higher frequency components in PTE
coming very much with the similar from
the similar way so that we shift the
auto so in general shifting the auto
regressive part now into the frequency
domain and outputting more things
together at
once. So this brings me now to um to the
to the final part. Um I tried to
introduce the concept of of uh spatial
challenges which which result in a way
that we need a better way of we to to
compress to encode simulation into a
latent space or compress scenarios
physics or whatever you want to call it
into latent space. um coming or aligning
with the concept that uh measures are
extreme extremely huge and the degrees
of freedom we are modeling there are are
small in often small in comparison to
what we usually experience. So we come
up with encoding and decoding challenge.
Secondly there is this temporal
challenge which somehow relates to
generative modeling iterative
refinement.
Now coming to a few use cases. Telling
you at the beginning we had this
rotating drum where we had these
particles and these particles were not
um it was much more challenging than
expected to model these particles um
because we were putting all everything
into this this this neural network in
this numerical way of predicting
accelerations and then updating their
positions. This is from a from a recent
work we did um where we were actually
modeling um I think this is 300,000
particles and we're modeling these
particles um going down in this in this
hopper as it is called. You can think of
this as grains. Um the the mental shift
we did is that we went away from
particles. So we treat every particle as
a realization of something like a
displacement field and we model the
whole um the whole pro process as just a
field changing over time. Actually it's
it's not 100% correct. We have two
fields like we have occupancy field
which tells you if there is mass or not
and this this um this displacement field
which tells you what's the displacement
vector at each point in time that
reduces the problem drastically. And
that's how a neural network thinks about
it because neural network is very good
at learning a continuous representation
at learning how a continuous
representation changes over time and
equating this continuous representation
to the actual physics we're modeling. Um
it's very interesting because what you
see on the right that's the output of
the neural network as as you see it's a
field it's not the particle. Um and and
obviously we cannot uh construct
particles because the the network
representation is continuous. But did
sorry this made this problems u or
finally uh this was was closing this
fivey year gap I had in my my head of of
of how uh that it's not very natural to
model these particle systems with with
modeling each particle interaction but
instead trying to model the whole
behavior at at once.
Um and similarly we we we came to this
this this more challenging problem of of
having this as I introduced before as
having this uh multifysics um problem
where you have these particles bouncing
around with and interacting with a fluid
which is coming from below um which is
super challenging but now you can play
the game. You can look at particles,
encode these particles by by first
subsampling them, then encode then
encoding them locally and then basically
making global interactions. And
similarly, you can encode the fluid
components which you see on the right
similar to how you would encode um a 3D
would do a 3D tokenization with vision
transformers. Then you have two
representations in the latent space and
they just interact with each other
because it's very natural that these two
representations interact because that's
what the physics is doing as well.
Particles interact with fluid and then
we we use this this this representations
to to decode again a field. In that case
as you see on the on the upper part of
the simulation on the lower part of the
simulation on the left these are some
isosurfaces of the displacement field uh
because we cannot output particles which
works uh which works very very nice. So
and then in the latent space obviously
if you want to have this temporal
modeling you can make all these tricks
about as I said um um diffusion model
and so on and so forth to get
consistency to get things um modeled
correctly over time. So suddenly we we
managed to to get a very complex physics
problem into a representation which you
can actually work on and have a using
all the tricks from computer vision all
the things which are shown by us from
from people um working on on on stable
diffusion and follow-ups apply this to
very complex physics setting and getting
a way of of handling this.
There is another thing which which I'm
quite excited about this concept of of
latent space modeling and that is that
you can decouple the way what you encode
and what you decode. I think this is a
super important concept in many areas
mostly in areas which are relying on a
mesh. If you talk to a CFD expert, um he
will explain to you that getting the the
mesh, the correct mesh on which you can
run your simulation is actually the
painful part um because or is at least
as painful as running the CFD simulation
because the discretization the
convergence of the simulation um and so
on and guarantees they come with the
choice of the mesh. So if you want to
make an engineer really happy, you avoid
both the meshing and the cumbersome part
of running the
simulations and meshing is not only a
problem in CFD. It's in in in many other
problems where you run a simulation
which is based on a mesh. It's just that
CFD is very very easy to to explain
because we have this nice um data sets
of cars which you can show. What that
means if you're able to um encode
different ways of represent the mesh
either by having a simulation mesh or by
just having a cut geometry or by by
having the um the the output of a large
language model which describes the
geometries or whatn not you can get this
latent space representation and then
what you can also do you can predict
different things you can predict on the
surface you can get unified prediction
for drag and lift coefficients for if
you if you can look for cars you can
predict ing the volume around the car um
and and and so on and so forth and and
even if you have interacting systems you
you can use this unified representation.
So this decoupling or looking at this
this latent space allows us to mix
physics allows us to decouple the way we
encode and decode and therefore opens up
a very new door and very new field um of
of modeling. And then there is this
thing that that you can do really crazy
things with that. And I I'm at the
university only for two years now I
think for one and a half. Um and I
started to to have really really smart
students. Unfortunately not every
student is doing the all the time what
you tell them to do. And there is this
special type of stubborn students who
who do um things even if you tell them
that it's not a good idea to um to do
that. Um one of these students is
Florian Cest. So he he basically um is
very was very keen on doing molecular
dynamics modeling. So molecular dynamics
modeling is the way of uh what the
challenge is you have a molecule and you
want to predict how the molecule um
moves over time. problem is that uh if
you want or if you model that um
numerically you you solve a stoastic PTE
um and SDE because of of this lash
dynamics which introduces stocastic
noise terms and if you want to model
that as a from a neural network
perspective that means that for each
future step you get a different
probability distribution of where these
atoms are. Um that is the the name of
the game modeling the trajectory of
molecules with a measure of probability
distribution how they evolving over
time. Classically you would use
something like a graph neural network or
a transformer where where each each node
represents a each atom presents a token
um because this has a very very strong
inductive bias. It is mass conserving.
So each atom is represented and and a
node in a graph network is not
destroyed. So you're not destroying
mass. The neural network has
automatically the number of atoms.
Right? That's how you should do it. But
if you want to do it as a latent space
modeling, you're destroying mass. This
is not good. That's why I said um I
think even if you're excited for you,
you cannot do that because the systems
we showed you before, you have a a bulk
modeling. You have this material running
out. you have this this general behavior
which you're trying to learn. It's the
same behavior if you have three thou
300,000 particles or if you have 300,000
particles and seven additional ones that
the overall behavior is not changing
that particles are not so important um
very different to molecules on the other
hand was very very um motivated by this
latent diffusion concept this latent
modeling and how we use the latent space
for really learning dynamics and the
interesting idea or the the way this
this was was made to work uh is by
including some sense of ID tracking
forcing using the the the the benefits
of a latent space but actually adding
some ids to the atoms that the encoding
is guided by by IDs and we learn to
restore these ids. So even if we if we
if we get into an unstructured space
this this encoding is so powerful that
there is meaning to this unstructured
space. It's very very intu
counterintuitive, but it works extremely
well. And this is this is one of the the
times where you you actually realize
that that students are smarter than you
and you basically just let them do
whatever they they come up with and and
and and and be um be amazed by the
results. So how this works um
conceptually, you add some ids to it. Um
so the input tokens have now a position
feature but also an ID and you train an
autoenccoder to to um encode and decode
this this representation and then in the
latent space you can use um this this
modeling um this generative modeling. So
what this is doing is on a molecular
modeling on a molecular level very
similar concept that we see in latent
diffusion just I'm using the concept of
um of having a very uh different encoder
which takes um which takes um
information of of atom types and using a
latent space where where you model the
the temporal evolvement basically again
as a tensor where you where you attend
over the different time dimensions. S.
So this is a bit how you can imagine you
get the encoding and then you in the in
the latent space you you fill the you
you you learn this diffusion
process. Finally um one work I I want to
talk about because this is science talk
which excites excites me a lot and where
you see the power of of latent space
modeling is if you if you go to to
simulations which are even higher
dimensional and one example of those is
is nuclear fusion. In nuclear fusion
when you want to model um the the
turbulence you would go to a
fivedimensional framework which is
called caroginetic framework um where
you have three spatial dimension and
three velocity dimension. One of these
velocity dimension is cancelling due to
symmetry reasons. So you end up with
evolving ions and electrons in in terms
of distribution functions and and that
allows you to model uh um to model
turbulence. Needless to say that this is
very cumbersome numerically. Um a neural
network can have a big improvement
there. Again it's the same game as as as
we know all the time in in what I
showed. You have a lot of
um you have five dimension to compress.
So you need a very good compression. You
need a very good encoder to come to a
latent space representation. But I think
e now it gets even more clear that we
need a latent space representation on
which we can run our models on which we
can run our um our predictions on which
we can um use our temporal updates to
get to to to get forward in time to to
to understand and to analyze the systems
and to make prediction. And the the the
harder these challenges are, the harder
these systems are, the more the benefit
of latencing, the more the benefit of of
having this these strong temporal models
is is
becoming. And and this is basically
coming um coming slightly slowly to the
end of my talk. I I first of all, please
don't take me too serious. This is my
personal view of of of modeling. My
personal struggles I had during my my
last years of understanding what's the
best way of modeling space and time.
I'm coming from the field of of uh of
engineering or I'm addicted to the field
of solving engineering problems.
Engineering problems in my opinion many
of these problems will only be solved in
the latent space. We are very lucky to
have such a bunch of smart people from
computer vision who show us what needs
to be done. The temporal challenge I
think has to be completely rethought in
machine learning. I think temporal
modeling is very much um not solved by
autogressive modeling. So we will have
to switch to a a more um chunkedwise
generative modeling approach and and uh
and again um and time and auto
reggressive modeling have to be
rethought. And that's the end of my
talk. I I think I'm I'm time and uh
obviously would be very happy to to
answer questions. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk. as we expected. Yes,
it that was fascinating. Thank you so
much. Yes, let's have a Q&A
sessions. If you have any questions,
please unmute yourself and then ask
questions. Um maybe I can start um in
general like big picture.
um this latent space um yes I mean I I
do agree that that's very important
um but in order to um form the latent
space you must have have uh first some
highdimensional data you have generated
and if for
example if you are relying on the
generating data on those highdimensional
uh simulation such as fivedimensional
gyroinetic um simulation that that takes
a lot of times. So the generating data
itself can be very challenging as well.
So how would you um if you have any
thoughts about that? That would be
actually now the topic for the next
talk. Right. So so we we we talk I mean
it's a it's obviously it's the absolute
first question to ask and it's it's a
it's it's a great question. Um so I
would say
um this talk was I I talked about
modeling. So, so, so how we model things
um obviously now if you really want to
to to to get an impact you have to to
really understand uh to which problems
you attach yourself that's why I said it
in the beginning and these machine
learning models are only powerful in
combination with data certainly the the
answer is not to to to use all the
compute and all the compute hours to to
to get them a few numerical simulation
which you can train on that's like this
chicken egg problem. I think that you
you you for example in many of these
these simulations you can produce much
much cheaper simulations very very um
easily and basically train your models
already on this this easier simulation
on this um more um coarse grain
simulation or low fidelity simulation
before actually going to the high uh um
resolution simulation. But technically
the nice thing is if you have kind of a
latent space approach you can train
these latent space models and you kind
of the only thing which you really um
need to be sure is encode and the
decoder are correct and therefore you
can also have a lot of
um call it transfer learning call it
different data sets calling different
modalities you have the chance to
include a lot of more data types a lot
of more data into this modeling so I
don't I can can't give you a a a
concrete answer of how you would um
circumvent this problem of of generating
data in the in the first place but I can
only say that if you have such such
latent space architectures
u it's much easier to deal with
different amounts of data which in the
end might enable us to understand better
what kind of data you actually need to
to really get fast surgates for a
specific problem. Yeah. All right. Well,
thank you. Um so so
uh the questions are piling up. Khaled
uh is asking Khaled actually if you can
unmute yourself and then ask it verbally
that would be awesome. Would you mind
doing that? Am I audible? Yes, you are
audible. Yes. I I just have a very basic
question is that like I I completely
agree that when you use like sequential
models to model the latent latent
vectors like LSTM, RNNs and
transformers, they usually the
performance usually degrades over time
as they are sequential. But but this is
a very basic question. How would they
how would you think of temp
incorporating temporal dynamics in a
generative model? because as far as I
know is that you only learn the
probability distribution of the
generation not the temporal dynamics
itself. So how would you incorporate the
temporal dynamics in a generative model?
So basic question in a in a generative
model. Yeah. Yeah. I would say in
general I you can think of as a temporal
model as something which outputs the
next time step but you can also think of
a temporal model as outputting a chunk
of time steps and iteratively refining
this chunk of time. That's that that's
what the video models are doing. They
you basically have a chunk of of of of
latence and you iteratively via
diffusion process refine them. And also
you can think of an LLM as outputting a
whole text and then iteratively
diffusing about on this text. And um
that the whole this setup works for
deterministic and and and probabilistic
modeling. So you output in the in this
lambslide molecule paper we output the a
whole trajectory and over each each time
step in this trajectory is part of a of
a flow matching process and gives you
the probability.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Um, so Millard, do you want
to unmute yourself and ask questions?
Sure. Uh, am I audible? Yes. Okay.
Thanks uh for the great talk. Uh, so my
question uh is about uh getting to the
latent space. So I'm wondering is there
a way to identify how much we can do
subsampling or like minim uh minimizing
the number of super nodes before we get
to the stage that the we are we are
having information loss and then that
affects the overall training of the
model.
I would love to say obviously but I
think this is not obvious question. The
answer is unfortunately no. I I think
that uh so so um in language is very
intuitive for us how we tokenize and
basically you would look at a text and
you just use a tokenizer and here we go.
um in engineering or in these many of
these challenges. This is absolutely no
not intuitive and even getting the the
right way of of how much information you
can um you really need to have in the
latent space how how heavily you can
subsample how heavily you can compress
this is really something which is not
very much explored. I I very much
advocate that there is a lot more
research going in this direction because
this is actually really what is needed
if you use latent space modeling. So I
would love to say yes there is a concept
the sad answer is there needs to be
research done in this area but this is
might also be exciting.
Thanks. Awesome. Maybe adding something.
Um I work a lot with people who model
this particle dynamics and something
like with discrete element
methods. You there's really like there's
works showing how little the number how
small the number of degrees of freedom
is actually actually is in a system of
100,000 particles which is very
motivating that this latent space maybe
can really be very very small.
uh related um before going into Looney's
questions uh was um the Millard um uh
asked about the self-sampling. If you go
back to the up encoding of physical
system
slides probably in the beginning and I
see that self-sampling is pretty very
structured. It doesn't look like a
random um if you can elaborate more on
this specific examples how you chose
those self subsampling strategy. That's
a good point. Uh that's actually error
in the in the in the um sketch. So
obviously this this should be a bit more
random not not so structure preserving.
Um but it's a very good point. So the
way we currently subsampling many of
these problems you have an underlying
mesh and this underlying mesh is in
simulations a mesh is always very fine
grain when when there is a lot of
variation when the gradient between
different mesh cells is very large and
when the when the flows or whatever
physics gets laminar the mesh cells get
larger and larger. So if you just sample
randomly according to each mesh cell
basically preserves more information
where there is finer mesh cells and then
more physics is happening. Um that's a
very good sampling strategy. Um
obviously I don't think it's the best
sampling strategy. Um I generally from a
from information perspective and I have
people looking into that. Um the
subsampling is a very fundamental
question to to ask. I don't have the
answer what to do it. I just have the
have the feeling that this might be
something which is worth doing really
proper research. Yeah, totally agree.
Okay, thank you. Uh Luning, do you want
to unmute yourself and ask questions? Uh
okay. Yeah. Hi, thank you Yu for letting
me ask the question and uh thank you
professor for the great talk. uh I also
love the idea of learning those dynamics
in the latent space and recently I'm
working on some data set come from
molecular dynamics or face field
modeling and they basically involve some
fundamental process like the spinodal
decomposition and dendrit growth and uh
and they are all very local dynamics.
The material scientist they are very
interested in for example learning on a
smaller graph and directly evaluate them
on a larger graph and they already show
that it is possible even without uh any
further training like zero shot uh
extrapolation on the larger domain. But
if I trying to do any like introduce any
encoder decoder process I just feel the
special extrapolation becomes very
worse. So I I'm not not sure if you uh
have come across similar problem and uh
such kind of your latent space modeling
could you have some yeah just uh just
I'm just curious have you ever uh faced
those kind of problem and do you have
any idea to make it uh yeah make it
better or it is just not possible. No
this is a this is a very good question.
I I would say um what latent diffusion
is telling us that basically um you can
have this lossless compression and this
this latent space modeling works
extremely well. However um in many of
these cases as you as you correctly
pointed out it's very hard to get that
to work. So the name of the game is
first how to get these very good
encodings. Um I mean in the end also for
this molecular dynamics paper it was the
most challenging part or basically 90%
of the work or that this big
breakthrough of Florian was to get a a
lossless encoding of molecules in a in a
space which is which is unstructured. If
you if you if you have that then then
running the diffusion model or whatnot
is is is basically just plug and play.
Um so I I think what what your question
is is more or less my my my scheme of
the talk that latent space modeling is
extremely powerful. The research in in
our areas like in in science and
engineering should should be really
focused of how we get to such a good
latent space representation. It's not so
clear. It's not as clear as it is in
language and is as it is in vision. So
my understand my uh experience to maybe
answer the question at least a bit is
that we always got it to work but it it
depended on the problem and it was
sometimes extremely hard and it always
needed some kind of tricks to make it to
work.
Okay. Well, thank you. Probably not not
satisfying
but all right. Um okay let me ask
another question. I was pretty
fascinated by that ID based tracking
idea that uh your smarter students came
up with. Yes. Um I I can you elaborate
more? I'm I'm puzzled. Okay. So you said
the input token token not only includes
the uh the features and positions uh of
the each individual molecules but also
you assign some sort of ID to it and and
then you u put it into the encoder and
I'm I'm wondering what's the size of the
that input token and that's it that
corresponds to individual molecules. So
yeah. Yeah. So each ID is basically
union. So each atom gets assigned an ID.
So if it's carbon atom, you would get I
I don't know ID7. It's an hydrogen atom,
you would get ID3 or whatever. Um and
and and then basically this this is um
so so you have um you run your ID
through some sort of film encoding and
then you stack positions and features
together and that's your input vector.
So what you have to do is you have to
have a list of of ids and those ids
obviously have to correspond to to
different atoms because what you would
then do in the in the decoding you would
basically give the list of of uh of uh
ids and this list of ids corresponds
obviously to the number of atoms and the
decoder would give you back the
positions. So in that in that way the
the knowledge or the the inductive bias
you have is to tell the decoder what are
the um atoms you want to retrieve. You
can give the decoder obviously a
different number of lists and it would
give you something back but obviously
then it's physically not correct.
Okay. So the decoder does not outputs
the ID. It's it it outputs the position
based on the ID based on okay. It's a
you can think of it it's a a reverse
it's a reversed field. Normally you
would output the position you get in a
value. Here you put in the ID and you
get the position out.
Okay. Interesting. I I will definitely
look in um to the paper and get the more
details out of it. Okay. Uh Rosel do you
want to mute and ask your questions
please? Oh hello. Um so yes um thank you
for a wonderful talk. So my question is
a bit more general is kind of like where
should we go from here? So do you
believe we should um kind of like impose
like some structure in these latent
spaces or especially to improve out of
distribution generalization or do you
believe we should just let them free and
just let the encoders learn for
themselves? Uh so yeah what do you
think? Um it's a good question. Um I
hear myself. Can you maybe So if you can
mute okay I can mute you. Um I would say
that starting with a latent space
modeling all this that the game starts
fresh. So um the question of how how
good we can generalize how how could
we how how consistent we we can be and
so on and so forth. um this needs all to
be tested and and and re-evaluated
um because many things are just very
different the way you model it. I would
definitely say that that time modeling
is is is can be done very differently
which give allows us to do a lot of um a
lot of nice properties. Also with these
generative models you have much more
flexibility which I think relates a bit
to getting out of distribution better
under control. But there is not I also
cannot give a satisfying answer except
that um now when when we when we
basically know how we tokenize and model
new problems we have to to to kind of
redo all these the studies we did
before.
Okay, great.
Thank you. Um, thank you very much.
Is there any other questions? I'm I'm
I'm debating myself whether I'm going to
ask this question or not that the
numerical route. Hello, Isa. Oh, so you
you have a question. Yes. Can I ask you
a quick question? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Go
ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. Yeah. Thank
you. Uh, overall like it's a great talk.
I I've been following your work and so I
I just like want to ask like a very
general question like um so do you think
there might be a latent space that kind
of allows us to learn some um you know
multi-kill um features because when you
kind of give the motivations earlier
basically the modeling often the case
are you know have different skills and
uh and and do you think this latent
representation being like encoder
handling in different scale and that
kind of we can have some uniform
representation on this latence and that
you know that that would be like very uh
efficient to represent like some some
physical systems. Yeah. Uh it's a great
question. Um so I I the the way I
presented this of having these two
different
um modalities I call them physics
modalities like particles and fluids
interacting with each other. You can
also think of two different scales
interacting with other with each other.
So so basically uh if if you have a
multi-cale problem you you you can um
use different encoders or different
different tokens for each scale and in
the latent space let these tokens
interact with each other. I think the
the conceptual leap um is to to to
identify what you you see as a different
modality in your problem and that can be
anything that can be material that can
be scale um that that that can be um I
don't know and and and then um let these
these this these different tokens do do
the magic in the latent space. This is
how I would model multi- scale and and
not saying that I'm doing it right now,
but um I I have very very similar ideas.
Yeah, sounds great. Yeah, thanks.
Awesome. Okay. Well, is there any other
questions? I think it's times up. Um I'm
sure Jo you have a another schedule for
the conference. I'm Thank you very much
for having me and thanks for the amazing
questions. That was very very
encouraging and and very very cool to
see. Johannes, I mean you gave you
actually bombed us with a so many uh
exciting uh the models you have
developed so far. So um thank you so
much for that. Thank you so much for
having me. All right, greetings to to
the west coast.
All right, let me uh stop the recording.